un encuentro bilateral que duró poco más
de 45 minutos en los que los temas
centrales fueron el cambio climático la
situación en Venezuela y la lucha contra
las drogas en el primer tema en el
cambio climático precisamente el
presidente colombiano le propuso a
Joe biden que Estados Unidos y Colombia
fueran de la mano para descorbanizar las
economías no solamente de Estados Unidos
y de Colombia sino de el continente es
decir dejar que las economías de los
países del hemisferio dejen de depender
del Carbón del petróleo y del gas en ese
sentido le hizo también una propuesta de
Gustavo Petro a Joe biden de cambiar la
deuda pública de los países de
Suramérica por acciones climáticas una
propuesta que según el presidente
colombiano Joe recibió con buenos ojos y
se comprometió a llevar al fondo
monetario internacional para que sea el
fondo monetario la institución
financiera que logre llevar esta
propuesta a hechos además se habló de El
de la lucha contra las drogas y
obviamente el tema de Venezuela fue
central y cuéntanos que otras reuniones
ha tenido Petro en Washington y cuál es
el balance hasta ahora de su gira por
Estados Unidos
inició su gira en San Francisco después
en Nueva York y en Washington tuvo
estuvo Desde el miércoles no solamente
en la casa blanca sino también en el
congreso en el congreso precisamente se
reunió con varios miembros de la cámara
de representante y del senado para
tratar el tema de la ayuda Colombia en
su lucha contra el narcotráfico el
presidente colombiano argumentó en
varias ocasiones que
habilitar más recursos para la lucha
contra la droga para habilitar más
Tierra productiva al campesinado pues le
daría más recursos a que los campesinos
se enfoquen en producir alimentos y no
drogas y esto ayuda a limitar el número
de toneladas que exporta Colombia a
Estados Unidos en cuanto a drogas
también se reunió con el líderes de ongs
y con otros líderes de la comunidad
colombiana acá en Estados Unidos para
tratar pues temas del acuerdo de paz
también y de la paz total en la que dice
es clave la ayuda de Estados Unidos para
lograrlo solamente este esta paz con el
grupo de las FARC sino con otros grupos
paramilitares y guerrilleros en el país